les barquettes
bon complique angie dis moi tu me fait
le plaisir de venir encore se tourner
avec le groupe la ligne passion la
chanson acadienne
que son roman pour dix mois mais
franchement là je suis incroyable je me
sens incroyablement bien joué de la
musique entre bons amis et eon cela
règle le tournage se passe
il fait beau je pense que c'est qu'ils
verts ont regretté ce moment un qui va
faire froid
un constat sur toi par hasard quoi parce
que tu vas me rentrer dedans je sens
tout à la fois un truc
ton sourire et en 06
j'ai entendu dire que les bizots était
une forme de langage tu veux qu'on en
discute tout à l'heure vous n'êtes pas
des chaussettes mais vous fait une belle
peur mon amour pour toi c'est comme la
diarrhée je peux pas me retenir
c'est parti et du coup un sais pas si tu
as un coût mais tu les perds mon mieux
je me présente clairement deux
[Rires]
on s'est empressé traction
[Musique]
savoir
faire avec ça alors ça va
est-ce que vous avez déjà entendu des
enfants être heureux de manger à la
courtine je vous emmène
bon appétit
tu as vu le soir
quant à fin mai dit il manque des choses
à la maison pour aller acheter ben je
prends mon vélo et je mets les courses
ici
tac
tueur attaque
on prend le vélo et on rencontre des
gens c'est leur anniversaire c'est sage
les anniversaires je les ai nniversaire